rafale trois escales sont mes pieds je
répéte y est ça va être beaucoup entre
eux où ils qu emmanuel c'est une
histoire qui dure depuis une dizaine
d'années des mois de travail pour
arriver à établir cette complicité une
méthode celle du haras de la cense on
travaille avec un animal donc
il faut connaître la tuerie là un peu
différent nous danser fonctionnement il
ya des modes de communication qu'ils
sont propres donc il faut les apprendre
et ensuite essayer de communiquer avec
lui pour lui faire comprendre qu'on a
envie de partage avec lui depuis les
années 2000 le haras base son éducation
sur la compréhension et la confiance
précurseur dans ce domaine il a résumé
sa méthode dans un livre ponctuée de
théorie et d'exercices pratiques
sortie le 20 avril il s'adresse à tous
passionnés professionnels ou amateurs
d'un livre de référence donc on peut
rentrer dans pioche est allé un peu en
un mois l'un pas en aval les feuilles à
ces chapitres mais c'est surtout un
livre qui transmet de la connaissance de
la pédagogie et qui donne les outils
donc on souhaite que tu fasses diffuser
le plus largement petit part que ça
améliorera la relation entre la mutual
c'est vraiment une synthèse sur
l'éthologie sur les principes
d'éducation des chevaux et puis après
128 exercice une méthode progressive de
manière à transmettre le plus le plus
facilement à chaque couple cavalier
cheval une quarantaine de spécialistes
participé à l'élaboration de cet ouvrage
le haras propose également des stages
avec ses intervenants le lieu sera
ouvert au grand public lors de ces
rencontres
du 15 au 17 septembre prochain